hi my name is Yan ribbon and today I
will present new features from system
over five everything for how you can
interact with other software to how the
two has been gone more flexible for
different use scenarios
okay let's get started my name is Yomi
oh God I'm going to talk about the
latest release a sister model which was
released I think around June to remember
correctly this year and I'll show the
some of the new features and of course
not all of them but give an idea of what
we added and but before I do that I'll
start with this slide which of course
should change think the stylesheet here
for these conferences it's a bit small
but yeah just wanted to talk a little
bit about what we aim to with sister
modeler so it's a system modeling tool
as the name says and the idea is to have
something that isn't only modeling and
simulation but it all actually takes you
the whole way with analysis also and
design work and that's where it combines
with the world from language and that's
actually something you you'll see in
five that we have integrated more with
evolved from language than we've done
before and we are presenting the
software in another way we're actually
not to really distinguish in whether you
have Mathematica to or not we're looking
at the tasks and some tasks might
require the combination of well
Mathematica and system over others might
be purely Mathematica or purely system
other we not really caring about that
we're looking what is it you want to
accomplish and presenting it that way
instead when the SS the Wolfram language
is has a holistic approach so we try to
have something where things work
together where you work work with one
area and have some reason for combining
it with another it should just work and
all of that is to make it a very
accessible tool that you can use in if
we look at in education you should be
able to use it in almost any class in an
engineering engineering program and if
we look at industry of course in many
different applications tomorrow I will
have a couple of examples of real
life scenarios so top key features first
we have something called if my
functional and mock-up interface
I'm not going to showcase that because
it's kind of not very easy to to show in
this kind of environment but what it is
is it is a method of exporting your
models in so-called functional mock-up
units that can be used in other programs
or take function mock-up units from
other programs and use them in system
order so for instance you might have
some legacy code from some other
software might be what's in competitor
like Simulink and you want to move to
system modeler then you can export that
code into an FM you import it to its
system order and use it from within the
tool and this is integrates with a wide
range of tools like at least 30 probably
more and and more and more tools are
adding that support so it's a great way
to to interact we added support for new
components I will go back to that a bit
more later so I'll not talk about it now
we also add in more ready-made models
which I also will illustrate a bit more
in a bit we update the diagrams so they
should be easier to read easier to
understand look more so the icons you're
seeing should be easier to relate to the
real world kind of correspondence we
made it easier to configure models and
this is something I will illustrate soon
so I will do that with an example of a
car we will switch wheels in a kind of
nifty way we improved package handling
meaning that if you are working on
larger projects you might be
collaborating with several different
peoples and you want to show change the
structure of how you store things let's
say you have stored everything in a
single file to begin with the project
expands and you want to have it
where
together with another colleague then you
might not want to work on the very same
file then there is easy now to actually
split into different levels the files so
you can work on your separate files and
of course you can you can use them in
your whatever you're using it SVN CVS
and so on the next parametric simulation
I will show is actually a bigger topic
than just parametric simulation but that
was what kind of fit into their graphics
but I'll get back to that we have tried
it to make it easier to get started
several different things came into that
for instance the updates of the icons
but also making different use modes so
you have have modes in system order that
are we're not exposed to all the
different menus and so on that are
available to kind of clean up so you get
the basics part the part and get get a
quicker start also added better examples
and so on and finally which we have
every release better performance so I
will wrap up with that ok so let's look
at this first as I said we have added
support for new model libraries and
that's kind of the core of system alder
to have a lot of components that you can
use to build up new models in this case
the release the biggest new library or
most important new library was media you
also add in noise library and added a
bunch of components in other libraries
but I will talk a bit more about me and
why that is interesting so the media
library what it has is it's basically a
bunch of media properties for different
type of gases and it makes it possible
to model something here's a very simple
example of where we have we are trying
to look at the stresses caused from an
expanding gas in the inner vessel let's
look at that model okay
to open up the help so yeah we can
actually doesn't want to let me super
say there you go
so the help will describe a bit what you
can do with example and so on and that's
actually one of the things we worked
quite a lot with to make each example
better documented so it's easier to
actually replicate and do your own but
let's then check at this particular
example okay so here's the example we
have our container down here the
container has is connected through some
sort of wall here that has some some
conductance where we went might lose
energy and/or transport energy and in
any direction of course and we have the
Sun that gives sound and now in this
model we have used we're pull data from
Wolfram Alpha to get the temperature and
lean shipping for a day this spring and
we have imagine this is a 1 cubic meter
kind of container that we're put out
outdoors we want to see how this gas
expands so if I simulate this now there
was another simulation where since my
preparation will actually get back to
that
okay so what did I do okay sorry
there you go so we simulate here it's
perhaps not that easy to see there you
go so here we have two boundaries the
upper limit is where we will have for
sure this vessel will explode or
something like that and then the lower
one is where we would should have a
warning which means that right now this
kind of works and we're seeing kind of
distress in we have inside the container
I mean the pressure in the container now
what we can do with a media library so
this is using one specific gas so if I
click here I can see it's very small but
I have a list here and it says I'll read
it for you it says that it's a ideal gas
of h2 from NASA Glenn coefficients so
it's like the official NASA tables for
this gas and then there are a bunch of
different gases to choose from that kind
of fits this scenario so I could choose
some other gas like moist air in this
case and see whatever happens when I use
that instead I actually have no real
idea what happened here why okay
division by zero that was not good so
air was probably which means that it's
process that it kind of exploded so yeah
so so you change gases and and we'll see
what what kind of happens when when you
do that so for instance if you want to
model refrigerator this might be
something that is of interest or a
compressor or some kind if afterwards
you want to see more about the examples
for each of these I have actually put
links here that you can follow to get
examples online that you can also
download afterwards okay so I haven't
changed the title here sorry so this is
not the right let's remove the title
so continuing on this or kind of
configuring your models I'll do an
example of a car so let's say configure
turbo model something like that was that
spelled kind of correctly at least and
and what I'll do I'll open this in
system modeler and we get this model
here we can see that a they say as you
said dry line of a car so in the middle
we have a powertrain and then we have
four different wheels and just as in the
media example we have dropdowns list
here so we can change the type of
powertrain we have so we chosen to have
two different levels of source of power
trains that we can choose from but we
can also change which type of tires we
have in this case we can use summer tire
and asphalt summer tire on gravel summer
tire and ice so let's try summer tire on
ice and I don't know if you notice but
these icons here changed because we
changed tires so let's do that again
and we changed to summer tire on gravel
and they change but of course it's not
only the icons I changed the equations
behind the scenes change also
so now if I simulate this we will
simulate a scenario of this car driving
on gravel with these summer tires I
actually try that with my bike the other
day when going out here for some reason
you have a tendency to like to have
gravel in the in every single crossing
the rest is just perfect but in crossing
you like gravel here what's up with that
it's just dangerous okay so this is how
this simulation looks like it might not
be that easy to see what's happening
what we're doing we're plotting that for
different wheels and how they're moving
so we can kind of realize it's doing a
turning around here and we can look at
okay this was some other simulation I
think what it was actually sliding a bit
more so you do the new and we it's
easier for us to actual
to see where is oh sorry it is yeah so
we see is kind of sliding through there
through the corners in the gravel so it
kind of loses a little brake grip get
the grit gets the grip again and so on
so this ability to to build models are
recoverable configurable makes it much
easier for you to develop a model that
you can then send to somebody who can
play around and test different scenarios
easily yet again this is available on
the website so I'll just show how it
looks like when you're on the website
let's do that so you have the full model
some examples and you can actually
download it to try it afterwards we kind
of get the idea of how how it works okay
so it was titled here even example how
links I used that before but not it was
more complicated back then so I think I
had a title parametric optimization on
the first slide but what the ACE is
actually we can do a parametric
simulation and this is so this allows us
to use the results in different sorts of
ways like for instance for optimization
so let's look at an example of that
using the classical howling scenario for
it so I start by opening in that model
here in Mathematica it hopefully open
here yep so it's kind of dull looking
model but we have some sort of reference
for the higher and the links and then
these are interacting well the the
Linksys are eating hares if that's
interaction and and let's look at what
we can do with that if we look at the
notebook here and zoom in a bit is that
readable should we make it like that
okay so I'm not going to get through the
entire example here but also so the
function is this one doubles and
parametric's simulates value there are
several functions but this is one of
them a parametric simulate value so what
it does it takes a model and we tell the
model that we want to simulate it
simulate get the result for the number
of hairs in the number of lynxes and we
want the very least for parameter which
is the initial population of each of
those species as well as the birthrate
factor of each of the species
so let's simulate that once we simulate
it we will store that in this sim file
here and we can query that now saying
that we want 150,000 hairs to begin with
25,000 lynxes and the birth rate for
them is also set here and then we get to
interpolating functions as a result for
these two and we
of course plot this and in this case is
we're only plot the second which is the
number of of links as think but we could
let's me we could of course plot both of
them and we'll see that result okay so
it is nice we we get the result that we
can plotting against each other and so
on
but the important thing with with this
isn't that now we can use this to create
small programs for instance for
optimization but in this case we'll use
it more for making an interactive
interface a snap in manipulate that will
show us let's see does it fit kind of
yeah so let's do that like that so we
have here a manipulate that uses this
simulation and we can set the number
that the birthrates up there and what we
see is the number of hairs and Linksys
at any given point in time this is the
initial value so i can change that so
let's say this is the initial balance
and we will get the kind of circle of
life for these two species or we change
the birth rate of any of them and see
how that effects the population so these
kind of functionality at whether it
makes it easier to use together with
mathematic and get snappy good results
so performance as I said we have
increased performance and and that kind
of takes us back to the first thing we
talked about media models media models
are typically quite demanding when it
comes to computational power so if we
look at these this diagram here we can
see examples of some of of the media's
actually with with our previous version
of system over we could load parts of
these media libraries we've done that so
the four first one did work but we can
see that red showing how much time it
took to simulate those and the two last
ones was weren't possible to simulate
with 4.3 so meaning that it's 2.7 to
kind of infinity times faster to
simulate today so these kind of data
heavy simulations have become much
faster so if you're doing anything of
that this is a this is a big benefit of
then you release then as I said we have
we have added a lot of built in examples
we have all examples are downloadable
there are actual also built in today or
on almost all of them every example that
doesn't require an additional library is
built in but in also more documented
have stored plots and so on and we also
made it possible to access them easily
from within the Wolfram language so we
can run in command W some examples and
this will give us now this takes some
time online because it is analyzes all
the libraries I have and I happen to
have quite a lot of libraries so if you
only have the standard that became black
who knows okay
typically doesn't look black like that
[Music]
but anyways we have the different
packages that might contain an example
so I could for instance dig they are
down to I say I take biochemistry here
click on that and it will tell me within
this examples package
you have an example you have some
example to run so I click that and there
we have 8 different examples that look
very boring I think I opened
yeah actually here this is kind of
interesting the other example here this
circus Arcadian oscillator does anybody
know why this is interesting read about
the mock Nobel Prize in in medicine
afterwards and you will will know why
yeah so so it was actually the one that
kind of research around that that gave
gave the Nobel Prize in medicine this
year so this way you can you can kind of
access them if we take let's take the
example we just looked at before or I
think some other industry examples I'll
take something by random here heavy
equipment
active damping I can then kind of click
on it simulate it directly I will get
the results from reading her without
having to know anything about it I can
access the documentation and so on
so it makes it easy to explore and find
things especially when you don't have
this black background that kind of came
here for presentation reasons ok so
that's a quick overview of some of the
new features but basically we one could
say that we have improved it like in
every kind of aspect there has been
improvement from usability to
performance and we have a couple of
presentations coming up still so after
this one today there's one on the
Wolfram language in integration and that
one is actually looking into the future
so you will see a you get will get a
taste of what's happening next and it's
pretty cool at least if you ask Roger
and then tomorrow I will present three
different examples from industry and
they are pretty cool if you ask me this
one example for how you use it to to get
analyze liver function
in order to get better liver treatment
5% of Americans have liver disease by
the way so it's kind of an important
thing and you can't really analyze liver
function today there's one on how to do
helicopter landing autonomously on the
ship and there's one on producing clean
energy using Stirling engines so those
three examples I'll show so they're from
different customers of ours and then
there will be one that I don't know
anything about because it's I have not
been involved so I will go to that and
see is reinforcement learning with
system molar sounds interesting and then
down at the basement there's a hardware
lab where you can try out and see how we
can use model-based design to play
around and understand more of a system
and you can actually what we have there
you you you get the link to download the
material so you can play around with it
at home so with that I'll thank you very
much
[Applause]